setting the conditions for long-term
growth with world-leading ambitions and
legal Frameworks for our Net Zero goals
and ensuring our banking sector remains
well capitalized and resilient to shocks
so we're working every day to grow our
economy and deliver on this and the
other government priorities
that the IMF say that we are doing just
that so thank you crystallina to you and
your team for all their work and I'll
now hand over to you
you very much Chancellor good morning
everyone and a very warm welcome to this
IMF press conference on the UK Article 4
consultation
we're very pleased to be here with so
many of you this morning and of course
uh greetings also to those of you who
are watching us online my name is Julie
Kozak I'm the director of communications
for the IMF and I will be moderating the
discussion today you should have all
received the relevant document our
concluding statement I will now turn to
crystallina gergieva our managing
director to make some opening remarks
after which we will turn to your
questions crystallina over to you thank
you very much and thank you Chancellor
for the award uh welcome great to be in
London on a sunny day and I want to
start by expressing my congratulations
to the people of the United Kingdom for
the coronation that took place recently
his majesty uh Charles King Charles III
Queen Camila May their reign be a time
of
prosperity
for this great country
now turning to the economy
the UK authorities had taken decisive
and responsible steps in recent months
this has
promoted macroeconomic and financial
stability
during a time of heightened
Market volatility
their efforts
and the recent decline in Energy prices
are beginning to have a favorable impact
on the economy
we now anticipate positive GDP growth of
0.4 percent for 2023
a 0.7 percentage Point upgrade over our
forecast from early spring which was as
you might recall minus 0.3 percent
at the same time as we also heard from
the chancellor inflation remains
elevated
this reflects the impact of adverse
terms of trade shock from Russia's war
in Ukraine and historically tight labor
markets
they are still recovering from the
pandemic
we expect the impact of these factors to
ease
and together with tight monetary and
fiscal policies bring inflation down to
the bank of England's two percent Target
by mid 2025.
they are significant risks to this
Outlook
why the global economy remains highly
uncertain
a sudden tightening
in Global Financial conditions could
restrain credit and Export demand and
depress GDP
High inflation
could fit into price and wage setting
setting expectations which would keep
inflation elevated
for longer and therefore it would
necessitate a tighter policies to bring
it back to Target
so what we have in this challenging
context is a very responsible action
from Bank of England tightening of
monetary policy
and the spring and Autumn
budgets that are aligning fiscal policy
with the objective of monetary policy to
fight inflation and to stabilize that
over time
we would like to
stress that a lot of credit is due to
the
re-establishing a financial stability in
the UK after the pension fund stress
episode last fall and also how
decisively authorities here acted at the
first sign of financial distress in U.S
we very much welcome The Windsor
agreement
it resolves disputes around the Northern
Ireland protocol with positive impact on
the business environment
so let me uh finish with the four
priorities we recommend in our
concluding statement first monetary
policy
remain tight
in order to keep inflation expectations
well anchored bring inflation to Target
we might see some additional tightening
of conditions
we may see rates staying longer for a
longer time higher
but this is a necessity
to bring
is to households in the United Kingdom
cost of living is
impacting especially the more vulnerable
among the severely
we need to see real incomes recovering
and people having the opportunity to see
a tangible improvements in their lives
second
fiscal policy needs to stay aligned with
monetary policy to fight inflation and
to rebuild fiscal buffers
what we recognize is that in the medium
term the fiscal strategy will have to
account for spending pressures
to ensure adequate Service delivery
especially in health care and also to
bring more investments in skills in
innovation in infrastructure in the
green transition
third financial sector policies the
authorities have done a good job
to keep Financial stability in focus
that needs to continue strong oversight
of both large and small Banks monitoring
of liquidity buffers and at the same
time
don't lose sight of the
non-banking financial sector where
vulnerabilities might get
exposed in tight Financial conditions
important that the financial regulatory
reform protects UK Financial stability
we at the fund take it to be a global
public good it's very important for
people in the UK but it is important for
the world as a whole I want to finish
with what is so
positive in the policies of the
government
emphasis on structural reforms to
sustainably boost UK's growth potential
we strongly endorse the measures already
taken the increase of child care support
the introduction of capital investment
allowance in the spring budget and we
see that the chancellors foreign vision
Enterprise education
employment everywhere
we see that as being a concept that
practically would make a difference for
the competitiveness and the growth
potential of the UK
targeting key growth areas thus
manufacturing Life Sciences clean energy
that is all
on the right track
so what do we propose in the concluding
statement
more of those evidence-based reforms the
policy and Regulatory regime for
businesses can be made more stable to
boost investment with wider and we think
best to make it permanent capital
investment incentives
smaller firms access to finance and r d
support
can be strengthened and investing in
skill education and Health Care can
enhance labor market productivity
critical for growth so to sum it up
where are we like the weather outside
the outlook for the UK economy has
improved
but in the context of a highly uncertain
global environment structural challenges
and still very high inflation
UK authorities have demonstrated
their ability to overcome hurdles in
difficult times and we look forward to
continuing our constructive
collaboration for
strong and inclusive growth in the
United Kingdom
thank you very much and now I see
questions popping up
so thank you very much crystallina I
will now turn to your questions I would
ask that you please identify yourself
and your outlet and please limit
yourself to one question we'd like to
take as many questions as possible let's
start here mirin
hello managing director Marine Khan from
the times the IMF has been consistently
accused of being a bit too gloomy about
the UK's growth prospects particularly
after brexit and today we've seen this
is the second upgrade in two months 1.3
percentage Point swing from what you're
forecast in January does that actually
vindicate the fact that you have
underestimated the UK's resilience and
have you asked yourself the question as
to why you seem to keep getting it so
wrong
uh let me uh give you the factuals as to
why we are upgrading the projections for
growth for the UK
and there are three factors behind
one
when we did our previous projection it
was in the midst of financial stress in
U.S
as well as the event in Switzerland and
at that time
we have not yet seen what we now see the
positive of the decisive action Bank of
England as you know there was a risk
with the subsidiary
of the U.S Bank here in in the UK that
was resolved instantaneously decisively
and overall the
demonstrable strength in dealing with
distresses in the UK is a source of
confidence
two we are now seeing in the surveys the
benefits of more predictable
relations with the EU
coming from the Windsor agreement and
that is boosting confidence as well
three Energy prices have received it and
they are giving us some uh different
perspective so when we look at the
increase in the projections they're
basically
confidence measures taken by the
authorities congratulations for those as
well as some improvement in global
conditions
philodric at Bloomberg given the limited
fiscal space which you describe would
you say that tax cuts should be a
priority policy or what other policies
would you uh would you recommend
what what we see is that the government
is prioritizing can greatly sold the
fight against inflation inflation is a
tax on the British people and in that
sense bringing it down is the most
immediate
benefit for incomes that the government
can and is determined to deliver in the
medium term we do recommend
measures that can increase the capacity
of the government to invest in
structural
measures
more specifically we recommend closing
down some of the tax loopholes
making
the valuation of real estate more
accurate more aligned with where we are
today
and also looking into the potential for
more aggressive action on carbon tax
that would insensitize more investments
in the green transition and actually
likely add to the competitiveness of the
British economy
let's go over here on Joel
Joel Hills from ITV News
when do you think living standards will
begin to rise again in the UK
well we we do see the UK economy growing
moderately in the next years
and of course
this is a very important condition for
living standards to improve in the UK we
are very encouraged by the focus of the
government on structural reforms to
boost growth
and we think that the implementation of
these steps that can bring a growth to a
higher level in UK can help to improve
living standards in the country
so so we think we're talking about the
medium term over the next years 20 25 26
27 we are seeing these improvements uh
paying back to the British people
of course we also are very hopeful to
see more of those who are currently
outside of the labor market
getting an opportunity to contribute to
the economy and this attention to skills
as well as to opportunities in other
parts of the country that may be
suppressed today is so so important to
bring as the chancellor would say uh
chance for Prosperity everywhere
right here at the end
Conway from Sky News
um managing director I wonder if you
remember back in Washington uh saying to
the chancellor on the economic forecasts
I hope you prove us wrong
well it looks like maybe he did preview
role I just wonder how how important is
it how big of a deal is it if the IMF
does keep getting things wrong does that
damage your reputation do you think and
what do you say to people here who who
who are saying why should we pay any
attention to the IMF this time around
questions so let me let me say two
things one that when you take a good
look at the projections done by Bank of
England consensus projections and the
IMF we are actually slightly less
pessimistic than others had been two we
have gone through a very turbulent time
over the last years we have experienced
shock upon shock upon shock
and that has created exceptional
uncertainty I I actually think that uh
our staff my colleagues deserve credit
for being agile in how we look at
changing conditions and being fast
to adjust projections so we can give as
clear a picture as we can at the time
that you would agree is the foggiest we
had seen in many decades
let's say uh David please
in the middle
oh thank you um David Millican from
Reuters um you talked about the sort of
Highly uncertain sort of global
environment could you say sort of what
the consequences would be if the United
States doesn't reach an agreement on
sort of the debt ceiling would that
means the recession for the United
States would that bring a global
recession
we
we have seen historically that the
discussions on that ceiling in the
United States have always been
uh quite um
pens
but always resulted in a solution being
found why because it is clear that lack
of solution would have a detrimental
impact on the U.S economy and on the
global economy so I am I look forward to
a solution being found this time around
it is your correct
to place your your question the way you
did that would have implications not
just for the U.S it would if it would
have implications for the world economy
non-desirable implications so
let's see how much this would be driven
to the 11th Hour
hopefully we won't have to wait that
long
I'm BBC News
um can you expand upon how your fears
about how sticky inflation is proving in
the UK and around the world and will
that require interest rates to go ever
higher
what we think is
headline inflation seems to have
reach the peak
and is now receding
and it is the result of strong and
coordinated actions
of central banks
but headline
inflation sorry the core inflation is
stickier
and within the core inflation
what is most concerning is food prices
being
the toughest to
to bring down
not just in UK this is everywhere
in this
environment of core inflation
even with Energy prices trimming down
staying
as high as it is it does mean that
interest rates will have to remain
higher for longer
the discussion around interest rates
has somewhat shifted
from how high
to for high law for how long because uh
headline
inflation is receding
and at this point uh the critical
action is this alignment of monetary and
fiscal policy that the UK has achieved
and the understanding that
there should be no premature
exit from tighter Financial conditions
because of the risk that would bring
to
wage price
correlation in the future
for how high for how long
the projections for the UK are that we
would see in mid 25
reaching the two percent
Target but of course
we have to stay vigilant
and be data driven Bank of England
the chancellor
need to watch the dynamic scene in
prices carefully
let's go right here
hello jump up for Rockets from The Daily
Mail
you talked about being your forecasters
being agile
some of the things that you saw in the
report on the upgrade include the budget
Energy prices coming down and the
Windsor framework things which had all
happened prior to the previous forecast
in April so I just wondered whether
actually
um rather than a forecast it's more sort
of looking in the rear view mirror and
you need to be a lot more agile and
perhaps even whether you think you need
to think about more carefully about the
way that you
um you do your forecasts because as
various other people have noted
um this is not the first time you've
been a bit too long about the UK
the
the projections we do
and published in April are actually
Based on data from mid-march
so there is this
lack that influences
how much we can
integrate in this projection
what you write some of the confidence
building steps were taken earlier
but their reflection in sentiments
has only been demonstrably
assessed now
so when we did the projections in
mid-march at that time
the concerns around Financial stability
and the impact of the stress that that
we have seen in U.S mid-sized Banks and
also the case in Switzerland the concern
was much more severe
the agreements around
relations with you
not very clear at that time how they
would impact business sentiment now this
is clear now this is clear and therefore
when when we disintegrate the 0.7 we can
point exactly to what were the
percentage points where we were more
conservative at that time and we are not
now
but this is the technicality of the
answer
what we are debating at the IMF today is
at the time
of more frequent and severe shocks
and
exceptional uncertainty
how do we communicate
our forecasts should we be
using our traditional
Baseline projection
or offering a range of projections and
this is a debate not just at the IMF
this is a discussion in the economics
Community
we are
in a world that has changed
more shock prone world and one in which
the impact of shocks
translate into
a
highly unpredictable set of responses
across countries
no question Economic Policy need to be
more agile in this environment and the
question the the question is not whether
it should be more agile the question is
how do we
operate in a more uncertain environment
and yet deliver
policy predictability for businesses and
households
Delphine
dolphin from the financial science
what's your recommendation on fiscal
policy in the run-up to the next
election
this is why Chancellor maybe
um
your choice to stay
um this is this is really a question
that is best addressed to to the
government to the Prime Minister
Chancellor from our perspective from the
from the position of the IMF we find
that this government has been very
prudent to prioritize not what is
politically easy but what is right for
the British people
and
I I am
very encouraged by
the way priorities for the budget for
the fiscal policy
have been set
fighting inflation clearly number one
priority with given the high high
numbers of inflation
improving the growth prospects
by putting evidence-based structural
measures in place
and being determined
to
take
decisions that are
benefiting people across the United
Kingdom
I think that that
so far we see a
determination that is
above
the political
Fray
hi Sue Chan from the telegraph um you
outlined a range of policies that you
think can boost growth but another thing
that the chancellor has been looking at
is um unlocking billions of pounds of
pension Investments through a series of
reforms that can make us more like
Australia or Canada do you think there's
an opportunity to boost growth there
um by allowing funds to invest in more
productive assets
well this is certainly a decision that
the country different countries take
differently
based on how they prioritize Financial
stability growth
these are trade-offs that have to be
done very carefully but the answer is
yes we do see a potential for increasing
investments in the growth potential in
in growth in United Kingdom and we leave
it to the authorities here
to come up with the exact pathway for
that
okay gentleman in the middle here
mm-hmm
oh that Jack Bonnet from City am just
touching back on fiscal policy and
potential tax cuts on the route into the
election I just wondering whether or not
you had an assessment of what that would
mean for the bank of England's point of
view you've obviously taught for the
fact that fiscal policy and monetary
policy still need to be aligned to
tackle of inflation
um if there's tax cuts potentially in
the next election does that complicate
the bank of England's position
I mean at this point there is no
intention to go for tax cuts because
again the government
is brightly prioritizing the alignment
of fiscal policy with monetary policy we
think that that alignment will have to
stay
for quite some time because
um
the government is aiming to get
inflation
down by half by the end of the year
that is not a trivial goal but in our
view it is achievable and the direction
to travel is the right direction
uh
one thing in our concluding statement
you might have noticed is that
we now expect the two percent Target to
be met six months later
and therefore that priority of
bringing inflation down has to be
ingrained in policy for as long as it
takes
and it is going to take a little longer
than initially anticipated
okay thank you we have time for two more
questions so we'll take the gentleman
here and then the gentleman here
Matthew Davis here from the national
um given your upgrades to uh 0.4 growth
how does this now compare with our
friends in the G7 and perhaps the G20
um
it compares favorably
we we are seeing
a
an improvement in the in the position of
the UK in terms of growth prospects
we
we are likely to see the UK performing
better than Germany for example
one mistake that we often make and I'm
saying that not for the press for all of
us is that we take we focus on one year
and one year is not the very best way to
judge performance of a country if you
look at the last three years
then actually the UK's performance is
quite good
vis-a-vis the rest of the G7 I believe
UK would be number three in the G7
context
so I think we have to recognize that
uh
the last month since the spring there
has been a very significant
turnaround in policy and that is
bringing benefits to the UK and the
people of the UK
and then last question over here
hi my name's uh Philip Inman from the
guardian I was going to as the last
question now I was just going to steal
two questions one was to press to press
you a little harder on uh tax cuts could
you say because there is a Lobby for tax
cuts could you say to them whether you
do believe that tax cuts are a route to
growth could you be a bit more
categorical in your response to that I
know you say there are no plans for tax
cuts but there is a Lobby for it and
also do you think in five years you'll
be coming back and talking about GDP
there's a lot of backlash against GDP as
a measure of uh the health of the
economy
um do you think you'll still be talking
about GDP in five years well um I think
I'm going to tolerate two questions
because they're both about important and
interesting questions if you allow me
um so
to your to your first question
um
the
focus on
fighting inflation
and I I repeat that it is so important
because
inflation is a tax and it is
the heaviest
on the poor
so getting inflation under control
is the right objective at the time when
we are seeing
record high levels
for over decades
when we take say we are beyond that time
when the fight against inflation is a
priority
then we look into
how the UK
can grow
faster and in a more sustainable Manner
and that would put pressure
on increasing spending in some key areas
well that has to be funded
and to be funded
that would require a very careful look
at revenues
we have come up with a list of measures
that would increase revenues and we
recommend to the chancellor to
to go through that list
and see whether they could be a better
Revenue site
in light of this pressure to increase
spending
so clearly that
I mean let me say that
of course
it is attractive to to look into ways in
which
the tax burden is lighter
to inject more investment opportunity
but only when it is Affordable
and at this point of time
neither it is Affordable nor it is
desirable because
if you want to reduce to to constrain
demand and increase Supply you have to
think what are the right policy measures
for it
um
to your second question
in
we all know that GDP
is a good indicator but not perfect by a
long mile
just to give you one
example
if you are
say say if I hire a gardener
and I pay the gardener that increases
GDP
if I decide to marry the gardener
that would decrease GDP
if you look at the impact of pollution
actually investing in activities that
degrade our environment
response GDP so we have to work on we
have to work hard
on helping policy makers to have a
better set of indicators to make
decisions on at the front we have a very
significant program on
closing gaps in how
the functioning of the economy is
measured including
by looking into
carbon intensity
vulnerability to climate shocks
indicators that expand our understanding
Beyond GDP but is GDP helpful yes so my
to to answer your question don't throw
the baby with the butt water
but hey let's give the baby good quality
food Let It Grow
well with that um thank you very much
managing director and thank you to all
of the all of you and those online
who've joined us today if there's any
additional requests you can reach out to
the imf's media relations team and now I
would invite the chancellor to make some
final remarks
and her article article 14 Ali Alfred
everyone who's worked very hard to make
today's report possible what we've heard
is a decisive vote of confidence in UK
economic management but we also hear the
warnings about global instability and
risk and I want to reassure you that we
will stick to our plan to keep inflation
down and Harve it and get growth going
and there will be a Relentless focus on
that by me and the Prime Minister going
forward thank you very much indeed
thank you
[Applause]
foreign